what's happening there citizens the
reject Nation we're here to watch
Brooklyn nine nine four times fifteen
John how are you I'm good I'm good how
are you sir good turning my phone on
silent to give Brooklyn 99 my undivided
attention so I can give a most thorough
analysis here ladies and Gentlemen
please if you are here watching this
video it would mean the world if you
could leave a like this is of dire
consequences also full-length Reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your
own copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine available
for a super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page cover a bunch of stuff exclusively
over there as well and uh we recently
launched a website where it'll make it
even easier to navigate the patreon for
posts and stuff if you know you you want
to like join or if you're already
joining you don't know about it and uh
yeah now we're gonna watch this so I
hope we all have good times here today
foreign
Squad here's where we stand vis-a-vis
whether or not the precinct will be shut
down
I think we'll be shut down God social
hearing wasn't until tonight Amy's
friend at HQ heard that maybe the 7-4
was getting shut down instead there's no
way that's true Amy doesn't have a
friend I do so
I only see her at work events and we
only talk through email oh God she's
just a colleague yeah well this is on
you sir I begged you for a task force
but no you wouldn't give me funding for
Strike Team Thunder kill Alpha colon
Hard Target you never told me what it
was for it's a strike team did
kills Thunder and puts its colon on her
targets need to know basis Holt it's the
last time I'm gonna stand up here and
look at you guys
the damn legs no
[Music]
open your legs Hitchcock
we're gonna solve a huge case before the
hearing tonight and then the NYPD cannot
shut us down a 10 year old had his bike
stolen we are EST in the B it's me
the way I see it if this is to be our
last ride then let us go out in a place
of Glory Charles think about anything
you ever wanted to do on a case we're
doing it today we're gonna drive around
in the coolest undercover car on the
impound lot undercover bucket list you
really think Herbie Fully Loaded was on
the impound lot without a doubt well
anyway it's a Mustang it's got a stripe
down the middle like Kirby okay one
question can we wear matching leather
jackets oh man I don't know if we're
gonna have time to pull something like
that oh hell yeah Blaze of Glory Blaze
of Glory Blaze of Glory I'm devoting my
energy to my new project Gene is on it's
a One-Stop online portal for my Legions
of followers speaking of Hume what's up
G Hive it's Queen G I'm bored at work so
you're not recording that sounds like a
bad idea for an already crappy day fine
Sarge I won't do it I will do it so you
can count this as my first prank I guess
unofficially you healed from your bus
accident
name one silver medalist Michelle Juan
Jeep Al Rosa she fell so much oh yeah
besides not about me wanting the record
for some respect Who currently has it
Hitchcock Hitchcock
at New York City in the 80s
80 Purge I always knew I was the best
cop in the 99 and now there's proof oh
yeah
five second rule do you want to copy
while you wait they made me an extra one
on accident oh sure don't don't trust
that
oh my God what is that submit you just
drank cement guys check back in and see
if she dies
that is messed up what is happening
that's a little something Michael two
breaks for the price
oh I gotta join that g life
I know you may not see yourself as my
mentor but of course I do I've been
mentoring you all this time what
under ordinary circumstances I wouldn't
reveal this to you until day 3300. it
was real
not anymore
so Mentor me if we don't work together
burn it there are 10 hours left sir if
you talk fast enough you can teach me
everything you have to take notes do you
think you can keep up let's just say I
was president of the stenographers Club
in high school for a reason was the
reason because you were the only member
yes
it's okay undivided attention yeah she
got good shorthand green grips orange
pegs I think it is
well brand sprinkler kind of has a ring
to it
lasts longer come on
come on over I mean this guy could still
make a break for it or take me hostage
or
have a huge bag of heroin Wowie
our savior and he's like Jesus yeah it
looks like a hunky Jesus yeah thanks for
the heroine
hunky Jesus oh he's coming in clutch got
to do something that I always wanted to
do make me sick hey we should get some
it was actually really helpful I feel
bad anyway
dealer named Dom who supplies half the
heroin in the city half of it he uses
BMX riders to move his product and as it
turns out when I was a kid I was avert
feet that's great news
I bet you're an awesome fluffer now I
bet you fluff those other Riders right
out of their biker shorts I could
picture you as a teenager fluffing all
of New York City General stop talking
stop it I get the job we take down Dom
Precinct saved then I do an ice pick 360
on the podium at the press conference
one question do you still know how to
ride come on riding a bike it's like
riding a bike really yep yes let's do
this
Hitchcock got a tattoo Mr nine nine oh
why are you putting a gun in your mouth
it's cool the barrel is fully inside
your mouth you're clearly
because he's got the arrest record and
you don't yeah suck on this click oh
it's
I got a case for you a guy that's phone
stolen at a bar last night she's a
crappy old phone I'd rather just get a
new one we're here to help you I only
saw us back uh he had a blue hoodie on
WOW
closed
so here's the plan my name is Tyler
Omaha born and raised in SoCal point me
to a quarter pipe and I'm gonna tell it
for days bro and I'm your roller skating
sidekick chip rockets and you're married
to the roller skates 100 roller skates
it is right chip Rockets
Rockets
fully gauge someone's character here's
what to look for grammar posture sent
attire what's the best type of shirt
collar English spread obviously but
let's hold the questions until the end
when people say good morning they mean
Hello when people say how are you they
mean hello there are two acceptable
sleep positions on back toes up arms
crossed or toes off arms at the side do
not trust any child to choose bubble gum
flavored bubble gum do not trust any
adult to choose gum at all never
vacation in them
happening in three days and my bookie
says if I don't pay him back he's gonna
kill my dog okay that's very intense
please let me win since my mom died that
dog's my only family I am so sorry I
shouldn't have engaged got way too real
I'm gonna lose everything yeah putting
on my helmet now ready oh no save body
oh my God he's great
Pro BMX guy do they bring in for this
stuff
[Laughter]
I see what I did wrong I did the jump
Bad
come on hot rod it's on my right hip I
sleep on that side it was stupid of me
to think I can make this the best case
ever let's just go back to the precinct
so you can make me hot cocoa I can't
believe I'm gonna say this but no I will
not make you hot cocoa oh I have a
bruise I won't do it not when there's
still a chance we can save the nine nine
what are you talking about I want to
keep down that guy
I planted a bug the GPS tracker on him
smart why are you in handcuffs because
I've been arrested by who Hitchcock baby
I busted his butt for finding a false
police report he broke his phone but
insurance wouldn't reimburse him unless
he reported it as
how the hell did you solve this
Hitchcock good old-fashioned detective
work yeah they have no idea they think
the phone was actually stolen you're
under arrest don't even think about it
I'm the greatest detective in the
history of here mr99 out
sniper binoculars here Charles tell me
how far away I am too close to measure
that's everything
let's do this
slo-mo walk check
oh my gosh there's way too much stuff
yeah and it's too heavy to carry all the
way back
how did Solid Snake do it well as for
outerwear only and silk is for sex
workers or musicians right good desserts
there are none if you were hungry you
should have had more dinner that's it oh
you've been mentored oh my God
my god oh no
we did it
it's over
yes I agree up down
separation
yes I agree
nice bowl of Misa Sue
no thanks Gina I'm not in the mood so
Gina this is that soup up for grabs
Scully no my followers are sick of
watching you eat cement
girls can you hear what they're saying
uh know really it looks like they're
talking they're making fun of Tyler
Omaha oh what I thought I was pretty
good me too and definitely don't look
anything like Rachel Maddow oh come on
come on a little bit they're getting
shipment at 8 30. whoa Dom's one of the
biggest dealers in New York whoever
their supplier is is gonna be huge we
gotta wait but that's two hours from now
we'll miss the hearing let's just arrest
Dom got to push the meeting to earlier
the 99 is going to get shut down
damn it I know it sucks but it's the
right thing to do no not that they're
making fun of Chip Rockets now these
drug dealers are so mean right go in
there guns blazing we're gonna get a new
partner his name's gonna be Heath or
Ryan he's gonna know everything about
die hard and he's gonna be super cool
jean jacket cool yeah yeah cool I'm
gonna check the distance on the
warehouse there
yep the building hasn't moved
still
0.1524 kilometers away wait are you just
holding up the binoculars so I can't see
you cry don't cry Boyle yeah I didn't
think so
come to think of it I'm gonna double
check our building distance as well oh
God
great visual I see you filming linetti
what's in a yogurt normal stuff nothing
you'd use to make a sidewalk with no
they decided to try to bring in a bigger
fish they're not going to make the
hearing so Jake's doing the right thing
instead of The Selfish thing
you did this to him
and holds a little bit nice see what he
thinks
[Music]
it's almost 8 30. we're gonna get into
position okay thanks Barb are you guys
crying
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm sorry that our last case wasn't our
best case ever no I don't say that
every case with you is the best case
ever
oh you too we still have a drug dealer
to bust right you know what that means
that's what I said both times okay
[Music]
hey
congratulations on getting the record
their bus case should still count you
notice a clue I missed Arsen I saw last
summer you gave me advice on how to
break the guy in interrogation blackmail
from 09 when you said the nanny did it
and guess what the nanny did it I don't
understand you're so hot Rosa
true that there are hundreds of cases
that wouldn't have been solved without
you you add all that up that's a record
nobody's ever gonna touch
congratulations mr99 thanks Diaz oh
sorry we couldn't you know save the
precinct nothing to be sorry about your
moral compass is on fire right now oh at
least we had an awesome bust yeah we
went back to back yes
the precinct will not be shut down they
decided to shut down the 7-4 instead
wait I don't understand apparently the
community came to our Aid there was a
swell of online support orchestrated by
an organization called gynazone oh no
way Jean is on
the G Hive is real I can't believe you
did it Gina you're a legend
because our mentorship is over I blew it
all in one day now there's life
experience there's more volumes of
course you think I could fit it all in
one binder
okay okay
you don't seem very excited oh I was
just adhering to section 7 page 145 no
emotional displays in the workplace
excellent I taught you well now if
you'll excuse me
um I have some work to do
on the roof that's
squeeing to do
not a doctor
I predicted the 99 would be all right I
called it how did you do that right from
you're beginning for this episode I was
like no no no there's too many Clues oh
there's too many Clues dude look at you
like how there's 14 seasons for this
show what's wrong Watson what's wrong
it's okay dude what's wrong is there
crime do we need to go solve some crime
Watson what's wrong about how you
haven't eaten yet
the crime of it's not food time yet
Watson what's wrong Watson what can we
do to make your life more enjoyable
Watson what's wrong how can we
accommodate you
um comedy yeah that was uh that's a fun
episode it was fun
I expect hilarity
did not give me hilarity I I think this
could have been another full-on
two-parter and it did not give me
hilarity so now it's a [__] episode now
I hate the shows oh no not at all see if
I was just watching the show at home I
would have been like
all right perfect next episode yeah but
because we're on camera I feel this this
calling to
criticize those super negative
territory because I wouldn't think if
there wasn't a camera pointed at me well
yeah yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't have to
put on any hat other than just your
enjoyment yeah when you were at home and
if I was at home I really like people
it's like I love sitcoms and I don't
watch sitcoms like bitten sitcoms and
like a laughing my ass off all the time
yeah and you just expect like you know
some episodes are gonna be like bangers
in some episodes they're just gonna be
pretty good yeah and this is one of the
pretty good ones it was fun it got some
good heartfelt moments you got to see I
like the moment with Rosa a lot given
this
just felt like they had a lot of good
setups that didn't fully go to to
lengths that the heights that Brooklyn
Brooklyn 99 generally goes with its
writing so yeah but he still had fun I
still really enjoyed it so I don't don't
feel this new dude really criticize it I
like the bike stuff it was really well
done
um you know Boyle and Peralta getting a
habit an emotional bro moment together
trying to live out an action fantasy and
also with Rosa giving all that to Terry
I thought the wrap around with Gina was
actually really clever that was
surprising yeah yeah that was really
funny and like they really snuck it in
like it's so the the main part they're
pointing you at is so dumb but yeah it's
like it's there the whole time that
she's live streaming and uh and I love
that that becomes the ultimate Saving
Grace yeah because it's the last thing
you would expect and it is kind of
annoying in the moment but just the
right amount of annoying to be like
perfectly Gina but also yeah not like
suspect of what the actual twist will be
and I even like the mentorship stuff
like for those two characters that felt
sort of momentous even like even if it
wasn't even if not every plot line was
always like bringing the jokes it was
like each one I was pulled into and I
liked the concept of and was happy to
see and I thought each one at some point
or another Rose to a height you know
yeah it was all still really it was
always fun and enjoyable
you know I wasn't like I didn't find the
the the binder mentorship stuff as like
hilarious or something yeah I thought
that I thought I thought it was that was
like we're getting some really funny
jokes a lot of it wasn't really that
funny to me I feel like there's like
amusing I was like yeah it's funny
there's lots sometimes I hear jokes like
especially you know at home and I'm
watching TV I'm like it's clever yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you just kind of note that to
yourself again but most of you don't
watch this show with a camera pointed at
you or you feel the need to make a
comment yeah
now I'm here to go and yeah let's let's
break this down act like I didn't really
I I no I enjoy it's most I could really
say for it is that I enjoyed it had a
good heart I like how they all came
together and they captured the spirit of
the benign and working together and what
makes this community so good yeah so
yeah I had a had a pleasant time I
didn't have a thought about something
yeah I don't think any of that Amy stuff
is going to carry over
yeah I'd be really impressed with this
show if they decided to actually instead
of just resetting yeah back to amyism
tropes but if they actually tried
carrying over the thing she was mentored
with as a running thing if they actually
did that but something tells me they
won't but I'll gladly be like oh show
you got me you got me just when I
thought I didn't I wasn't God and you
got me the the pitch of her not showing
emotion in the word plays makes me think
that would be a tall order but I'm also
I will root for it as well and also I
did think this one had some very funny
Scully and Hitchcock moments when he
gets that surprisingly yeah when he gets
that tattoo and when they arrest that
guy in the bathroom and just this idea
that because of the longevity
what's wrong what's wrong what's wrong
Watson what's wrong what's wrong what's
wrong Watson what's wrong come here
what's wrong Watson what's wrong Watson
Watson what's wrong Watson Hitchcock
though like him being this like
somehow technically still having this
crazy ass record just because he's been
around so long it's good if it was my if
I was the writer because this is always
the best way to approach a review I
would have honed in more on the clock
and I would have made them discover the
bigger fish sale at the end and then the
second one it would be like oh damn
we're not gonna make the meeting but
they actually do this crazy ass drug
bust and the show becomes like an action
show for one episode they really throw
down on stunts and violence and it's not
funny at all it's just crazy like bad
boys
and then we reset next week but you
can't but you needed this speech you
needed the whole speech that's true
though that is true no you would still
get the whole speech
because it was you know it would still
get shut down but then not shut down
oh hey copper
this one's the wild one this one's the
one who always wants to play like crazy
yeah he's the Mischief guy
who's who is he on the show he's a
Peralta
he's Peralta Mark the date what's the
date that we're filming this this today
is the day of Our Lord the 20th of
January
by the end of the year I gotta do best
cat moments a real region yes
it's going in there someone make a super
cut of every time a cat crosses in the
back
I love it I I love watching this this is
my favorite new show I should be filming
this from here this is a good it's a
good viral video
speed back yes
dude you're already looking buff this is
why I wonder I wonder why you're so
obnoxious so yeah so coppers Jake
Peralta and then that means that Todd is
is boil I guess
and then uh Watson's Terry yeah you guys
know who these cats are Sherlock is is
somebody else all right guys well it
looks like John's out of thoughts
unfortunately but I got so many of them
to save you guys
next week I'm gonna cut it short just uh
you know just everyone's got some
precious types I don't want to waste
anyone's alrighty let's answer sweet
patreon
I want John to shout out Brandon Benzie
Brendan Brandon Benzie ah you sound like
you could be from New York you know you
sound like you could be out here getting
the coffee walking here or something
like that but wherever you're from I
think you got a cool name every time I
see your name it's perfect because it's
like you got the comic book alliteration
uh and it's got a nice ring to it
Brandon Benzie I'm like I don't know
exactly where your last name your
surname originates from but it's Hebrew
and it means good Sun oh cool well hey
you seem like a good son you've
certainly been supportive to us whether
loving and domestic and uh and hey
that's perfect we're here to be your
YouTube daddies tranquility and comfort
yeah we we keep a chill-ass space in
here
like quality and hey you know we love
the Arts and uh if you've got that
artistic experience
us and in in discussions
personality number you're uh six we love
you six thousand I love music and
tiredness and attire dude this is the
tidiest iteration of the studio yet
there's always random music uploads not
crash and sleep and not finish
supposedly Charming intelligence
Charming intelligent Serene jealous
one of those words wasn't right I'm sure
but failed it you might be a little bit
jealous but don't be because you got
nothing to be jealous about in this life
your your money so money baby thanks for
the supporting us for being here buddy
awesome and we love you yeah yeah
Brooklyn Nine-Nine
[Music]